vous connaissez vous vraiment être fou
déjà allé à votre propre rencontre
investiguer au plus profond de vous un
jour j'ai eu envie et besoin de faire
davantage connaissance avec moi même je
vais vous raconter pourquoi et comment
tout a commencé lorsque j'avais 20 ans
mon confident le plus proche mon ami
d'enfance m'a écrit un soir d'été je ne
t'oublierai jamais puis j'ai reçu un
appel maxime était parti c'est comme si
on m'avait arraché coeur mes jambes ne
me tenait plus je me suis effondrée au
sol la souffrance et la douleur que j'ai
ressenti était si intense si dur pendant
de nombreux mois j'ai enduré une immense
tristesse et j'étais en colère
aujourd'hui je pleure encore son absence
mais le souvenir d'où de l'homme qu'il
était m'apaise maxime il avait le coeur
sur la main et dans ses yeux je me
sentais merveilleuse
malheureusement ces tourments et ses
souffrances atroces ont pris le dessus
et il est parti je pensais ne jamais
surmonté cette épreuve d'abord parce
qu'à 20 ans on est rarement confronté à
la mort on imagine que les gens que l'on
aime seront éternels et aussi parce que
je ne me connaissais pas assez bien pour
aborder ce déchirement avec le temps
cette douloureuse expérience m'a fait
prendre conscience que les épreuves de
la vie nous aide à identifier nos
ressources intérieures plus on va
apprendre à se connaître plus nous
allons être en mesure d'identifier nos
propres ressources et plus nous allons
les développer plus nous traversons les
épreuves en s'appuyant sur elle c'est un
peu comme naviguer sur une barque qui un
xavi râble au milieu d'un océan en
pleine tempête
aujourd'hui j'ai fait du souvenir de mon
ami une force et en sa mémoire j'ai
fondé des centres pour aider les autres
bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis et
les ali shair psychologue fondatrice et
dirigeante de plusieurs centres de santé
à lyon je vous propose tout au long de
mon intervention de répondre à des
questions vos réponses vous permettront
de savoir si vous vous connaissez bien
je vais également vous apporter certains
éléments théoriques de comment
fonctionne l'être humain puis je
terminerai par des pistes et des outils
pour apprendre à mieux se connaître nous
naissons tous avec un certain terrain
biologique et affectif une personne à
une autre ce terrain est différent en
d'autres termes dès la naissance un
contexte et déjà donné dans notre vie
pour autant ces conditions sont
évolutives ce qui peut influencer d'une
manière importante votre vie est ce
qu'on appelle les liens d'attachement
ceux ci sont déjà en construction des la
vie intra utérine et bien les
interactions avec les personnes qui
s'occupent du bébé en général les
parents un type d'attachement se
développe ce concept a été développé par
bowlby il détermine deux grands types
d'attachement sécure et insécure eux
mêmes organisé en trois sous type
d'attachement un attachement secure va
amener à l'enfant être plus en confiance
dans l'indépendance ou encore résister
davantage aux épreuves alors que
l'attachement insécure amène à de
l'anxiété de la dépendance affective de
l' isolement social des relations
toxiques ou encore un sentiment
d'abandon le type d'attachement et lui
même influencé par l'attachement qu'ont
eu vos parents à leurs propres parents
nous parlons donc d'un héritage
transgénérationnel heureusement après
avoir identifié quel est notre type
d'attachement nous pouvons le modifier
si cela est nécessaire en travaillant
sur nous grâce à une thérapie êtes vous
capable de déterminer votre type
d'attachement essayer de répondre à ces
différentes questions lorsque vous étiez
enfant est-ce que vos parents par
exemple été indulgent avec vous étiez
vous réconforter lorsque vous en aviez
besoin ou encore encourager
valoriser vos émotions et est elle
accueillie avec tolérance si certaines
de vos réponses sont plutôt l'année sion
peut-être avez-vous manqué de sécurité
affective est en plus jeunes il est
difficile de définir clairement sans une
prise de recul importante quel lien nous
unit à nos parents et finalement quel
impact cela engendre sur notre quotidien
pour ma part la mort de maxime m'a fait
comprendre quatre places il avait dans
ma vie quel manque qu'ils pouvaient
venir combler quelque 45 effectif je
pouvais avoir eu durant mon enfance j'ai
compris que maxime incarné en quelque
sorte une figure paternelle bienveillant
qui avec sa générosité savait me
comprendre accueillir mes doléances et
me redonner le sourire c'est son
souvenir qui m'aide aujourd'hui à
m'entourer d'hommes indulgent dans ma
vie maintenant nous allons aborder
l'attachement insécure ou autrement dit
le troubles de l'attachement celui ci
peut amener ce qu'on appelle des
traumatismes dans la théorie du psycho
trauma nous pouvons identifier les
petites et ainsi que les grands t ceux
ci peuvent arriver durant l'enfance à
l'école ou plus tard au travail comme
par exemple avec un licenciement ou
encore un divorce compliqué ou une
agression ils peuvent survenir sur un
terrain secure ou insécure ces épreuves
plus ou moins difficiles vont nous
heurter bousculé et dans le meilleur des
cas nous renforcer actuellement nous
vivons tous une situation traumato gêne
la pandémie mondiale
chacun à notre niveau nous traversons
cette épreuve différemment chacun avec
son terrain de base ses propres forces
et ses faiblesses cet événement vient
chambouler nos vies car cela y percutant
à tous niveaux est ce que vous pourriez
envisager cela comme une très bonne
opportunité pour davantage vous
connaître depuis cette pandémie mondiale
est ce que vous observez par exemple des
modifications de sommeil est ce que vous
vous sentez ébranlé dans un ou plusieurs
domaines de votre vie est-ce que vous
ressentez une augmentation du stress de
l' angoisse et pour faire face à la
suppression des ressources externes
comme par exemple aller au cinéma au
restaurant faire des activités
collectives avez vous développé des
nouvelles ressources
est-ce que vous avez remarqué des
qualités ou des compétences que vous ne
pensiez pas ouah est-ce que vous vous
sentez à la bonne place votre place je
vais vous partager une expérience
personnelle j'ai accouché dix jours
après l annonce du premier confinement
dix jours particulièrement stressant
angoissant même d'une part j'avais mon
entreprise et vous savez l'impact du coc
vide sur l'économie de plus je me
questionnais pour la santé de mon bébé
et en plus je ne savais pas s'il ne pas
pas allez pouvoir être là le jour de
l'accouchement le stress était à son
comble et pour traverser cette période
d'angoise qui est ce que j'ai fait je me
suis appuyé sur un outil thérapeutique
que je connais bien l'auto hypnose et
c'est grâce à cet état de conscience
modifiée que j'ai procédé à un dialogue
intérieur ont créé un conditionnement
positif essieux appréhender cette
situation correctement je suis puiser
dans mes ressources car je les connais c
est mon accouchement s'est très bien
passé davantage se connaître c'est aussi
connaître et se connecter à son corps
comme l'expression le dit le corps parle
plus nous sommes en lien avec nos
sensations corporelles mieux nous
décryptons nos émotions et nous pourrons
ainsi les nommer nous pouvons penser que
nous nous connaissons bien également à
ce niveau pourtant d'après mon
expérience ce n'est pas toujours le cas
je vais vous raconter une petite
anecdote personnelle déjà je suis hyper
active mes proches passent leur temps à
me dire ralenti et les ah cool
tranquille
repose toi il y a trois ans alors que je
venais de fondée il ya peu mon premier
centre de santé j'étais fatigué car je
travaillais beaucoup et puis on a décidé
de partir faire du ski un week-end pour
se détendre première demi-heure première
piste je suis parti à fond téméraire
comme à mon habitude
sauf que ce n'était ni le jour ni le
moment il neigeait la visibilité était
mauvaise et avec ma fatigue à votre avis
que s'est il passé je n'ai pas vu une
bosse j'ai fait un vol plané j'ai chuté
tout point de mon corps s'est retrouvé
sur mon épaule et me voilà tout en haut
des pistes une épaule fracturée
et luc si j'ai passé cinq heures
l'épaule déboîtée croyez moi ça fait mal
une douleur atroce l'horreur une
anesthésie générale et un an et demi de
rééducation plus tard j'ai enfin compris
écoute ton corps et là il m'a fallu
aller jusqu'à là pour enfin comprendre
l'importance d'écouter son corps seriez
vous identifier votre état physique
etes-vous facilement distraits elle vous
fatiguer comment décririez vous votre
respiration en ce moment comment se
passe votre digestion alimentaire
avez-vous des douleurs particulières
finalement se connaître est un vrai
challenge
les épreuves de la vie peuvent nous
pousser plus rapidement à se confronter
à nous mêmes il est aussi possible de le
faire de sa propre initiative et en
conscience pour cela différentes
méthodes sont possibles le simple fait
d'expérimenter la vie et de partager
avec les autres est un très bon moyen de
se connaître je pense aussi que sortir
de sa zone de confort tout en étant à
l'écouté de soi même sont une très bonne
chose pour découvrir qui nous sommes
réellement entamer un travail sur soi
permet grâce à l'accompagnement d'un
professionnel de faire connaissance avec
soin également aussi les états de
conscience modifiée tels que l'hypnose
ou la méditation sont de merveilleux
outil pour se retrouver face à soi même
observer et accueillir ses ressentis et
ses souffrances en effet ces pratiques
nous permettent d'être face à notre
petite voix intérieure et nous donne
l'opportunité de l'écouter n'est ce pas
là le meilleur moyen de savoir qui nous
sommes au fond de nous prenez-vous le
temps de dialoguer avec vous même est ce
que vous prenez le temps de vous
demander comment vous allez est ce que
vous êtes en adéquation avec vos valeurs
d'ailleurs connaissez vous vos valeurs
est-ce que votre vie correspond à vos
attentes vos besoins ou peut-être même
vos rêves j'ai une expérience
hospitalière où je réalisais des
accompagnements en fin de vie et j'ai
aussi une expérience aux urgences
psychiatriques où j'accompagnais des
personnes qui ont fait une tentative de
suicide
il s'agit ici d'un lien à la mort
diamétralement opposées pour ces
personnes les uns la subissent les
autres la provoc pourtant un point
commun majeur ressortait de ces
différents témoignages
la capacité à se connaître s'accepter
essais mais tout ceci permet d'être en
phase avec soi même est ce que nous
sommes pour aborder la vie et la mort
avec sérénité ceci permet quoi qu'il se
passe d'être sur une barque inchavirable
qui traverse la tempête au milieu de
l'océan lorsque mon ami est parti je me
suis dit c'est quoi cette vie à quoi bon
et puis je me suis dit j'ai le choix
soit je déprime toute ma vie je suis en
colère soit je fais de cet événement une
force pour lui mais surtout pour moi
j'ai choisi la deuxième option
bien sûr cela a mis du temps et au fur
et à mesure des expériences de vie d'un
travail sur moi ou de pratique
méditative et hypnotique j'ai appris à
m'écouter et encore aujourd'hui
j'apprends toujours à me connaître tout
ceci m'amène de jour en jour à davantage
de sérénité et à renforcer la stabilité
de ma barque je pense que la
connaissance de ce soir est un long
chemin qui permettrait de devenir le
meilleur compagnon de soi et jouerait
sur le confort de la vie nous évoluons
constamment il s'agit d'un processus
dynamique qui ne s'arrête jamais
finalement je reprendrai une célèbre
citation de socrate
connais toi toi même et tu deviens ce
que tu es se connaître globalement c'est
à dire savoir identifier et comprendre
ses émotions ses sensations physiques et
ses pensées sont selon moi précieux et
permettent d'être en adéquation avec
soi-même ses désirs et ses besoins c'est
pourquoi aujourd'hui j'aide les autres
accompagné d'une équipe
pluridisciplinaire et grâce à une
approche intégrative à trouver leur
équilibre intérieur
je vous ai partagé un bout de mon
histoire et vous quelle est votre
histoire qui êtes vous